good morning john earlier this week i
tweeted a question that i thought was
interesting do you think we will still
be using phones in 200 years and by
phones i mean cute little hand computers
side note i maintain that we call these
things phones because we saw that their
implications were so psychologically
overwhelming we needed to give them a
name that was really familiar being a
phone is one of the 500 things this does
like calling it a phone is like calling
it a flashlight but whatever steve jobs
was like iphone so we're stuck with
phone it will always be called a phone i
think this is a really interesting
question because we've had these things
for like 15 years so not very long and
yet life seems kind of impossible
without them like hear the kinds of
answers i got to this question number
one i sure hope not i hope that i'm not
using my phone in x number of years but
do you do you really i like this thing i
don't just use it because i'm addicted
to it it is a shockingly useful
rectangle some people thought that we
were going to return to a slower more
traditional way of life
i don't really see that happening
personally some thought that in 200
years we'd exist in some kind of
metaverse where we wouldn't need any
physical objects at all that also seems
unlikely to me to me like i don't know
some people thought that their
functionality would be somehow implanted
into our eyeballs or our skin or
whatever like i think that that might
that's possible but also even with that
i think would also be nice to have a
sturdy little rectangle around but also
a very common response to this question
was hank you think humans are going to
be around in 200 years implying in a
joking way that like arc do you think we
can make it through this now i admit to
being the more optimistic of the duo
here um but i think that both of us john
agree that
humans are going to exist in 200 years
and probably with significantly more
advanced technology than we have right
now like that's the most likely outcome
look i get it we're not done with the
pandemic part and yet we are
transitioning somehow into the the
tremendous geopolitical instability
caused by a dictator with a bunch of
nukes invading a neighboring country and
starting a horrific and unnecessary war
part and we get to do that under the
cloud of a global climate changing
faster than it maybe has ever changed in
the history of the planet it doesn't
feel good i agree we've got like the
cultural upheaval of a communications
technology revolution lining up with the
physical upheaval caused by an energy
revolution that occurred over the last
200 years and yes humans do have the
technology necessary and the weapons
built to destroy ourselves many times
over why i don't know i don't know why
why also i get that this is a joke it's
just a joke that i hear a lot and i'm
starting to like less maybe it's the
repetition but mostly it's the sort of
like giving into hopelessness vibe that
like that's the sort of fun thing to do
is just be like ah
hopelessness let's just give up
everybody i'm not saying that we are
actually giving up i don't see anyone
actually giving up i'm just saying
talking about it makes it seem like
giving up might be the cool thing to do
when it's definitely not like it's a
betrayal of the future it's a betrayal
of the past too it's also a betrayal of
the present don't give up we are only
past saving when we believe that we are
past savior i don't see anyone acting
that way not even close i see people
working hard for themselves and their
families in their countries and their
planet i see people disagreeing but i
don't see them anywhere close to giving
up this is a hard moment and obviously
different scales of bad for different
people and i don't know what to do about
it i read commentary from experts i
listen to them interviewed on podcasts
and what i hear is
this is bad we don't know how to fix it
and we don't know what the future holds
but i do know that 15 years ago we
thought this might be a fun when i
graduated from college i could not
imagine this thing even existing i had
an mp3 player that could fit 13 songs on
it and now i am having a hard time
imagining a future 200 years from now
where we don't have them we never know
where we're headed times are rarely
precedented but no one is acting like
they're hopeless
and that gives me plenty of hope john
i'll see you on tuesday